[Music]
hey daddy-o's welcome to the Sweetwater
secrets preview show for episode 203
chapter 16 the watcher in the woods as
always I'm your host and riverdale
expert Liana Galera and today I'll be
discussing your latest and greatest
season two theories + KJ APPA is
spilling some inside scoop about the
black hood and if we're gonna get to
know Cole Sprouse
a little bit more in our first burgers
and lies Fast Five but first up I just
want to say thank you all so much for
your kind comments about how much you're
enjoying these episodes of Sweetwater
secrets you know it takes a lot of work
and a ton of people to do two shows each
week so hearing from you guys is even
sweeter than one a Pops milkshake
so many many kisses to you but first up
I loved reading all of your hisses and
kisses in the comments you know there
were lots of kisses to Cheryl and
Betty's dark girl talk scene and plenty
to the Pussycats performance but there
was an overwhelming amount of hisses to
the fact that the black hood targeted
moose image Sofia loves pizza which by
the way I love pizza too said I just
hope that mid survived because she was
literally introduced in this episode and
we didn't even get to see her personally
like WTF yeah girl I agree
ron's Ronnie says I'm so mad about the
fact that they killed moose image I was
hella excited to see them me too and
Gabriela eyes gum bunim sorry if I mess
it up said why is everyone assuming that
moose and midge are dead we need
confirmation
I agree Gabrielle until we see a body on
the coroner's table yes I'm talking
about you Clifford blossom I'm not
ruling them out moving on to your black
hood theories now perfect fantasies said
quote I'm totally jumping on the
bandwagon that the black hood is someone
who's trying to cleanse Riverdale of its
sinners now this is interesting take
and it definitely ties in with this
week's promo for the watcher in the
woods calls himself the black
we're not waiting around for the next
attack from now on we're protecting our
own your secrets are sinless this is the
bloodletting sheriff Keller and how
Cooper are the main suspects but I saw a
few more theories in the comments that I
think are worth including in the mix now
iris petite some of tests said the black
hood is definitely the long-haired
serpent who gave jugg the jacket okay
s-so says my theory is that chick Cooper
is the black hood green eyes and from
what we've seen from his casting
descriptions is that he's a pretty hard
and guy my two cents and Claire palmera
says what if Smithers was the killer
that's not even funny Claire Smithers
did nothing to hurt anyone and I'm still
really upset that he got fired but it's
okay all right guys moving on now to
help us unveil some more secrets about
the black hood I caught up with KJ Appa
and here's what he had to tell me we've
got to talk about black hood Archie's
obsessed with finding whoever is
underneath this hood do you know at this
point in time do I know for certain yeah
like it would actually is no I've got no
idea really none of us have any idea why
do you feel like this is something that
is really tormenting Archie this season
I think she's very protective over his
family and over his friends
I think after free being shot and all
the other things that happened after
that no one has seen you it's just like
a build-up and I think Archie feels
almost kind of responsible in a way for
not stopping him the first time you know
I feel like actually we'll find any
reason to for it to be his fault which
is you know it's endearing but I think
that speaking of revenge a bunch of you
guys have been single bearing around in
the comments and talking about my
absolute favorite season 2 Theory the
fact that Hermione Lodge and navy Hyrum
are south side serpents ah I love it
here's what you had to say so Shay and
to say said every time I see a snake I
yell Hermione Lodge yes shashi says
Hermione and Hyrum snake Lodge love the
name change there and Bella Rooney 1 2 3
says Hermione is for sure a snake snake
emoji nice addition there girl
now guys I definitely agree that
Hermione is a snake in the grass but
whether or not she's literally a serpent
is to be determined now just how the
serpents have penny Peabody on the
inside of the law I definitely think
that Hermione could be their snake with
a ton of town power now what do you guys
think curl up in the comments and tell
me now the one thing that we do know for
sure about a watcher in the woods is
that Jughead is finally attending South
Side High so while the serpents will be
getting to know juggy I thought we could
take this time to get to know Cole
Sprouse a little bit more I asked him a
speed round of questions in our burgers
and eyes Fast Five what is your go-to
diner order ah that's gonna sound so
Jughead it really is the burger usually
it's like a bacon cheeseburger - you can
always trust some diner bacon I don't
know what it is it's always crispy it's
never too fatty
very Jughead answer which couple on the
show are you currently shipping you're
in a pretty good one I know I know but I
you know I think so on the nose it's so
it's so real huh what couple do I want
to ship sure I want to ship Kevin with
pretty much anybody at this point poor
guy which of your cast mates would you
trust with a secret okay Jay prettier
yeah uh tell us a secret about one of
the Riverdale sets oh man you're gonna
ask me to tell a secret right after you
ask okay I think this one's got the most
secrets this one was built off of
Rocco's diner but it can be turned into
a functioning diner
it's like a one-for-one recreation aside
from the walls possibly moving and
allowing it's such an accurate
recreation of a diner that you could
have a working grill which so I'm trying
to pitch the production that you know
during the off season we turn it around
we make a little money for the show we
start selling some burgers people who
come in the truckers on the route can
stop you know what I mean it's good I I
agree hey you've got a good business and
real life are you a vixen
a serpent or pussycat and why definitely
a serpent my brother and I when we went
to public school we even started a
little game where the force members now
cold I don't know man they disbanded we
lost that Brotherhood but all right I
would give anything to see Cole and
Dylan bring the force to Riverdale
alright guys that does it for this
week's preview show for a watcher in the
woods now come back to Sweetwater
secrets after you've watched the episode
for exclusive details from KJ Appa
Lily Reinhardt and more of your
Riverdale faves and as always please
give this video a like if you enjoyed it
hit subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel
so you never miss an episode and keep
shouting out your thoughts and theories
in the comments or to me on Twitter so
we can fangirl and guy out together
later river babes
you